زياره مليئه بالصفقات والاستثمارات
يختتمها ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه
25 عقدا ومذكره تفاهم بقيمه 29 مليار
دولار اوبريمات بين السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه في مختلف المجالات الصناعيه
والاستثماريه خلال الزياره شركه ارامكو
السعوديه اعلنت عن الاستثمار الاكبر لها
في كوريا الجنوبيه مشروع شاهين من خلال
شركات اس اوه يلا تابعه لها وبقيمه تقدر
بسبعه مليارات دولار ولي العهد السعودي
ذكر ان السعوديه الى رفع وتيره التنسيق
الاستثمار والتعزيز الشراك بين القطاع
العام والخاص مع كوريا الجنوبيه وتحقيق
الاستفاده الكامله من الفرص التجاريه
والاستثماريه الواحده
كبير منجزات اللجان المشتركه بين بلدينا
والطلع يرفع وتيره التنسيق الاستثماري
وتعزيز الشراكه بالقطاعين العامه الخاص
ونؤكد على اهميه الاستفاده من فرص
التجاريه واستثماريه الواعده والمتاحه
للتعاون بين بلدينا ونشيد في هذا السياق
بالنمو الايجابي في السنوات الماضيه
للمعدلات التبادل التجاري بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكوريا
الاستثمار السعودي خالد الفالح على اهميه
الشراكه بين المملكه وكوريا الجنوبيه
مشيرا الى انها تعد من اهم الشركات على
مستوى العالم
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكوريا علاقه
متميزه
من افضل الشركات على مستوى العالم اذا اذا
ممكن اقول فيها تكامل قوي المملكه لعب
الدور كبير في نهضه كوريا الحديثه بعد
الحرب الكوريه في خمسينات القرن الماضي
من ناحيه توفير الطاقه اللي نهضت وساهمت
في النهضه الكوريه وفي نفس الوقت الكل
يعرف ان الشركات الكوريه اااه كان لها دور
كبير والموارد البشريه الكوريه كان لها
دور كبير في بناء البنيه التحتيه والشراكه
في بناء الاقتصاد السعودي الحديث واعتبر
الفالح ان شركه اس اويل تعد من اهم
استثمارات شركه ارامكو السعوديه في الخارج
مشيرا الى ان قيمه مشروع شاهين يصل الى
سبعه مليار دولار
شركه السويد من اهم استثمارات شركه ارامكو
السعوديه خارج المملكه الان بتنتقل من
توفير الوقود والطاقه لكوريا واسيا من
خلال هذا الموقع الى بتسارع كثير الى
انتاج المواد البتروكيماويه فهو بيكون في
كراكر وبكون فيه صناعات متقدمه
للبتروكيماويات وبيكون في طبعا
خفض
للكربون فهو يعني مشروع مثالي قيمته همم
يعني بين سته وسبعه مليار دولار واليوم
وقعت ارامكو عقود
الانشاء وانا اعتقد انه مشروع يستحق
الاشاده به
من العاصمه الكوريه سول ينضم الينا المفضل
العربيه ميسون ويهضوا عقيل ابو 50 مرحبا
بكم
اترك لكم المساحه ميسون وعقيل الحديث عن
ابرز المشاهدات لهذه الزياره لولي العهد
السعودي لكوريا الجنوبيه
وكذلك ابرز الصفقات من اتفاقيات ومذكرات
تفاهم ايضا تم التوقيع والاتفاق عليها بين
الجانبين تفضل
فيها عقيل سنتحدث معه لانه اتفاقيه جدا
مهمه يعني اكثر من 26 اتفاقيه تمت خلال
هذه الزياره سنتحدث الان عقيل عن اهميه
هذه الاتفاقيات وخاصه بانه نحن نتحدث عن
مليارات
26 اتفاقيه بتكلفه حوالي تصل الى 30 مليار
دولار ميسون الصفه العامه التي تجمع على
الاتفاقيات هذه كلها تقريبا انها
اتفاقيات تدعم توجه الرؤيه في تنويع مصادر
الدخل في السعوديه همم وزير الاستثمار
السعودي خالد عندما تحدث للمستثمرين او
للشركات الكوريه همم اليوم هو 11 شركات
للاستثمار في مجالات جديده في السوق
السعوديه الطاقه المتجدده يعني هذا هو
السؤال همم
قيل هل هذا يكرس بانه السعوديه لم تعد همم
يعني تعتمد فقط على النفط وانما الان هناك
تحول الى اقتصاد جديد وصناعه جديده
في الطريق
لحل التحول في في اقتصادها وتنويع مصادر
همم مصادر الدخل عبر احلال قطعه جديده مثل
الطاقه المتجدده عبر توسيع نطاق الصناعات
همم داخل السعوديه سمعنا قبل همم
[موسيقى]
صناعه للسيارات الكهربائيه قبلها كان في
همم حديث عن مصنع اخر لشركه لوسيد في حديث
عن الهيدروجين الاخضر مع اقوى باور
الهيدروجين الازرق مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
كل هذه كل هذه الاستثمارات
ااا تتوافق مع توجه همم الرؤيه لخلق
صناعات جديده وتنويع مصادر الدخل في
السعوديه طبعا ايضا عقيل نريد ان
نتحدث ايضا ونشارك المشاهدين بابنهم هذه
الزياره لها ان اهميتها الاقتصاديه ولكن
ايضا هناك علاقات همم اخرى بالاضافه الى
العلاقه المتينه الاقتصاديه ايضا العلاقه
الامنيه العلاقه السياسيه ودبلوماسيه همم
مثلا همم حتى اليوم ولي العهد تحدث بانه
همم اكدوا على الشراكه مثلا بموضوع همم
الامن والسلم الدوليين ايضا تم الحديث عن
التعاون في الدفاعات همم
الصناعيه ايضا موضوع
المشاريع النوويه الصغيره همم دائما هذه
العلاقه بين البلدين كانت تربطها مصالح
ليست فقط مثلا اقتصاديه او امنيه او
سياسيه على حد سواء وانما كلها مجتمعه
واظن هذا ما الذي يميز هذه العلاقه بين
الدولتين
ميسون اذا كنت تتذكرين في عام 2000 17 كان
في
اختيار او تحالف ما بين السعوديه وكوريا
بموجبه كوريا همم اصبحت شريك استراتيجي
للسعوديه
لتحقيق مستهدفات رؤيه 20 30 همم كان هناك
زياره لولي العهد السعودي عام 2019 همم
الى كوريا اعطى الدفعه كبيره لوثيره
التعاون واللي عدد المشاريع همم الكوريه
في السعوديه والمشاريع السعوديه في كوريا
هذه الزيارات هي الزياره الثانيه ايضا
اعطت همم دفعه كبيره للتعاون
نريد ان نذكر ايضا
عقيل هذه السنه هي مرور ذكرى 60 عاما على
اقامه هذه العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وبين كوريا الجنوبيه
والعديد من الاشخاص لا يعلمون بانه في
السبعينيات عقيل وفي ثمانيات كان هناك
عماله كوريه جنوبيه في السعوديه ساهموا في
بناء الجسور لا ادري اذا كان لديك معلومات
بعد او فمثلا عن هذا الامر خصوصا الصحيح
همم الكوريين ساهموا في همم عمليات
الانشاء البنيه التحتيه في السعوديه وفي
دول الخليج في السبعينات
والثمانينات من بعد هذه همم السنوات كانوا
للسعوديه مثل ما تحدث وزير الاستثمار
السعودي همم اليوم كان السعوديه تدور كبير
في بناء كوريا الحديثه عبر امداد كوريا
بالطاقه همم اليوم ميسون احنا في همم
في مرحله جديده همم الشركات الكوريه
الكبرى التي اللي ساهمت في بناء كوريا
المعاصره مثل سامسونج مثل همم هونداي
تتطلع اللي اقتناص فرص همم اللي فرص جديده
للبناء في السعوديه مشاريع الجيجاكس في
نيوم في البحر الاحمر في القديه همم كده
مشاريع مميزه وهذا الشركات الضخمه اللي
موجوده الان في كوريا همم تطلع اللي ان
تكون لها فرص هناك اليوم كان في اجتماع
همم لولي العهد السعودي مع رؤساء
التنفيذيين همم للشركات الكبيره هنا في في
كوريا وكان همم الحديث حسب ما تم تسريبه
الى الان همم كان الحديث حول الجيجاكس في
السعوديه
وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه الشركات الكوريه
الكبرى
لهذه المشاريع
الملحقيه الثقافيه هنا في كوريا الجنوبيه
ايضا ناشطه جدا وموضوع اخر جدا مهم في
كوريا الجنوبيه وهو موضوع الابتعاث
العديد من المبتعثين المتواجدين في
كوريا خاصه في مجال الطب
وحتى في الشهر الماضي ايضا احد الاطباء
السعوديه
وايضا وصف بانه من ابرز الاطباء في اختصاص
صمامات القلب
هناك تبادل همم ثقافي تبادل ايضا همم
كما كنا ايضا شاركت اقتصاديه كبيره وموضوع
هذا الابتعاد الى اي حد برايك ايضا موضوع
هذا الابتعاث قرب هذا التعاون وجعل
البلدين يعرفان اكثر عن ثقافات بعضهما
البعض
التبادل الثقافي مثل ما تحدث لك السفير
السعودي في لقاء الاجلتين معه قبل يومين
بين همم الطلاب السعوديين او ما بين
السعوديين
والكوريين في في تزايد خلال السنوات همم
الاخيره سواء عبر التكنولوجيا اللي قاعد
تدخل لك البيت السعودي وهي تكنولوجيا
الجايه من كوريا عن طريق الموسيقى او عن
طريق الثقافه
العربيه ايضا قربت هذه يعني كوريا
الجنوبيه من السعوديه ومن غيرها ايضا من
دول الشرق الاوسط
امام شعبين شعبين همم شاب همم
سواء في كوريا او في السعوديه
في عندهم طموح كبير لصناعه الغد افضل
والقرار موجود من الجهات سياسيه في
البلدين همم فاتوقع ان المستقبل العلاقه
والتعاون ما بين كوريا والسعوديه راح
يتطور اكثر في وقت هو مميز فيه جدا الان
عندما نتحدث عن هذه المشاريع الكبيره مثل
اليوم ذا لاين القديه همم هذه المشاريع هل
نتحدث اتدخلت هذه الشركات الكوريه عليها
تكون هي منافسه لشركه اخرى ام تستحوذ على
مثل هذه المشاريع همم
ميسون انا اليوم وانا اسمع عن الشركات
الكبيره سامسونج
والفرس اللي ممكن تحصلها في همم في
المشاريع الكبيره في السعوديه في يوم
اذكر صور انك تشوفها وانا صغير للمعدات
الامريكيه وهي جايه
المنطقه الشرقيه في السعوديه للتنقيب عن
عن النفط انا اشوف ان السعوديين راح
يكونون على موعد لدخول همم معدات واليات
كبيره همم ممكن تكون موجوده في نيوم او
ممكن تكون موجوده في البحر الاحمر لعمليات
الانشاء اللي راح تكون في في هذه المناطق
هي مرحله تحول تاريخيه تعيشها السعوديه
الان همم لتنويع مصادر داخلها والانتقال
من الاعتماد على النفط الى قطاعات همم
عقيل في هذين يومين يعني من خلال تغطياتنا
لهذه الزياره همم ايضا تعرفنا اكثر على
الثقافه الكوريه وعلى همم ماذا يمتلكون في
هذه الدوله الاولى
انت اكثر من زياره طباعه
رائع جميل
فمحبه بكثير واجمل شيء فيه هو هذا الاراده
اللي همم جعلته ينجح الى هذا الحد يعني
كان عاملا واصبح الان يتفوق صحيح تاريخيا
في وقت قصير قصير جدا الان سنعود الى
زميلنا خالد لمتابعه الرابعه
[ضحك]
صحيح راح نكون ان شاء الله في في الرياض
في موسم الرياض خالد
نتابعك الجديد عن الفرق الكوريه اللي راح
تشارك طيب انا شاكر مقدم لكم تواجدكم
يعطيكم العافيه من
العاصمه الكوريه ميسون واهض وعقيل ابو 50
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]